aujourd'hui on parle de permettre
l'apparition du nouveau de remplacer les
vieilles histoires par des nouvelles
histoires et aujourd'hui on a entendu
des témoignages vraiment inspire waouh
en même temps je me demande ce qui va en
rester et ma crainte c'est que ce qu'on
se dit aujourd'hui ce soit oubliée dès
qu'on retourne chez nous en fin de
journée qu'on rallume la télévision la
radio qu'on retourne sur internet parce
que trop d'histoires et parlement
histoire ici je parle de tout ce qu'ils
nous racontent le monde
ce soit court comme un tweet ou longs
comme une série t que ça soit du
reportage ou de la fiction que ce soit
commercial ou partager entre amis on
peut pas s'empêcher de se raconter des
histoires on est comme ça nous les
humains c'est par les histoires qu'on
essaie de s'expliquer le monde sépare
les histoires qu'on n'apprend des
expériences et des erreurs des autres je
vais vous raconter une de plus une
histoire aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
d'une expérience que j'ai faites l'hiver
dernier durant laquelle j'ai passé 100
jours sans aucun média je vais aussi
vous parler de trois choix inconfortable
qui je crois peuvent nous aider à créer
du nouveau jeudi qu'ils sont
inconfortables
parce qu'ils demandent tous les trois de
nous extraire de notre tendance par
défaut qui est de nous laisser absorber
dans le tourbillon des histoires bon
j'ai pas besoin de vous dire à quel
point on assiste aujourd'hui à une
explosion sans précédent dans nombre des
histoires auxquelles on est exposé géré
ensemble et quand même quelques chiffres
pour mettre les choses en perspective en
août 1991 y avait un site web
il s'appelait le world wide web il
comportait quelques pages magnifiques
aujourd'hui 23 ans plus tard on en est à
plus d'un milliard de sites dans les
années 70 ont été exposés sur une base
quotidienne moyenne de
500 messages de nature commerciale par
jour aujourd'hui 5000
aujourd'hui chaque minute c'est 350
mille nouveaux tweets chaque minute
c'est deux millions cinq cent mille
ajouts sur facebook chaque minute
ces senteurs de vidéos qui sont mis en
ligne sur youtube
ça ça veut dire que si je veux regarder
tous les vidéos qui sont mis en ligne
sur les autos aujourd'hui il faudrait
que je reste assis devant mon écran 10
heures par jour pendant 40 ans et le
plus terrifiant c'est peut-être que
pendant ses 40 ans faudrait que j'en
passe 10 à regarder des vidéos de chats
qui font des states chaque jour c'est
plus de signer livres qui sont publiés
et qui viennent s'ajouter à la masse des
33 millions de livres disponibles sur
amazon ouais ça c'est sans parler de
toutes les histoires qu'on se raconte
dans la tête
les cinquante mille à 70 mille pensées
par jour de ce que je suis ce que je
suis poste que je devrais être que je
devrais pas être ce qui est bon ce qui
est mal et que bon 95% de ses pensées le
qui sont un ressassement les mêmes à
faire constamment mais on est on souffre
d'un embonpoint d'histoire on est sur le
point d'éclater
est ce que je voudrais suggérer
aujourd'hui c'est que le sentiment
d'être sous pression qu'on ressent
il vient pas seulement du fait que tout
votre trop vite comme on aime le répéter
ni seulement du fait qu' on essaie de
faire trop de choses en même temps
non ça vient aussi du fait qu on est
exposé à trop d'histoires minute après
minute jour après jour et que cette
surexposition mais elle génère un stress
chronique et quand on est stressé on
cesse d'être créatif et on devient
plutôt réactif c'est bien bien difficile
de générer du nouveau de permettre une
renaissance dans un environnement
comme ça qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
choix inconfortable numéro un
coupez les histoires comme je vous
disais j'ai passé l'hiver dernier 100
jours sans aucun média c'est un défi que
je m'étais donné donc sans médias ça
veut dire pas de revue pas de journaux
pas de radio pas de télévision pas de
cinéma pas de livres pas d'internet pas
évident pour quelqu'un comme moi
bon je ne permettait quand même des
communications individuelles d' que ce
soit par texto par e-mail par téléphone
vers des individus mais j'ai coupé tout
ce qui était messages dirigés par un
groupe de gens donc tout ce qui est
médias vous trouvez peut-être que la
chose est exagérée ou peut-être même
futile
j'aimerais quand même vous demander d
imaginer quelques instants qu'est ce que
ce serait pour vous depasser ils ont un
mois ou même une semaine sans aucune
nourriture médiatique inconfortable
ennuyant à 13 ans moi si j'ai fait ça
c'est pas parce que les histoires c'est
mauvais si au contraire parce que c'est
si bon c'est parce que j'aime tellement
à apprendre que jamais de conférences
tedx c'est parce que j'aime tellement
les histoires que j'écris de la fiction
que j'ai fait du journalisme que je
coach des gens qui veulent raconter une
meilleure histoire avec leur vie et dans
leur travail et quand j'étais petit je
pouvais pas imaginer qu'un jour j'aurais
envie de dire que trop d'histoires parce
que j'en avais jamais assez des
histoires j'étais insatiable je me
souviens quand j'avais 6 7 ans j'ai
rendu visite à mon cousin allons pierre
soit c'est cette photo d'un milieu c'est
moi le petit blond avec ma petite soeur
baba et mon cousin qui est dans rouge
donc quand je suis arrivé chez mon
cousin jean pierre je suis arrivé dans
sa chambre la première chose que j'ai
vue c'est qu'il y avait un tintin et
astérix que je n'ai jamais lu alors je
me suis emparé de ces vivres et je me
suis installé sur le divan pour me
régaler les mon cousin lui qui est un
petit gars sont plus actifs que moi
peut-être plus normal m'a proposé
d'aller jouer au ballon
là je dis non je suis plus envie de lire
il m'a fait une autre proposition puis
une autre puis une autre jusqu'à ce que
finalement être découragés 10 mai à
cause
c'était lac saint jean à cause des
plaques domaine
j'ai pas su quoi dire sur le moment mais
la vérité c'est que pour moi c'était pas
plate que ça sera jamais plate qui
arrivait plus à découvrir dans les pages
de tintin à apprendre que ce que je
pouvais découvrir en or jouent au ballon
mais aujourd'hui quarante ans plus tard
j'ai eu envie de faire l'expérience de
ce que ça peut être de vivre comme je
n'ai pas eu l'occasion de le faire
depuis que finalement j'avais 5 6 ans
depuis j'avais appris à l'est et qu'on
m'avait installé devant un écran j'ai eu
envie de retrouver un peu d'espacement
talent de plume sentir toujours sous
pression ou de l'avoir l'impression de
manquer de temps j'avais envie de
retrouver un espace de liberté aussi
parce que je devais bien constater que
au fil des années j'étais devenu de plus
en plus de dépendent de ce type de
nourriture mais en fait j'avais envie de
créer davantage parce que le temps que
je passe à consommer et à alterner entre
une chose est une autre c'est du temps
que je passe pas à faire que je pense
pas créé alors comment est-ce que ça
c'est pas assez
mais comme pour tout sera gelée premier
jour c'est bizarre et puis il ya un
sentiment de vie étant de fait confort
alors les premiers jours j'ai fait
beaucoup de nourriture
j'ai tenu mon appartement très très
propre
frais pour rêver mais assez rapidement
j'ai devenu le nouveau normal pour moi
et j'ai pu constater au fil des semaines
que j'étais plus présents plus présent
ce que je faisais puisque je pouvais pas
faire de multitâche veut pas écouter ou
regarder quelque chose en même temps que
je faisais quelque chose
donc j'étais plus en prise sur la
réalité
le chef de m'extraire aussi des bruit
médiatique à faire en sorte que d'une
certaine façon j'ai générer moins de
bruit à l'intérieur de moi aussi -
j'avais moins que cinquante mille
pensées par jour donc moins de bruit à
l'extérieur moins de bruit à l'intérieur
le résultat c'est plus de calme plus de
clarté mental plus facile pour moi de
d'entendre ma propre voix de de
reconnaître ma propre intuition au
niveau des relations les gens autour de
moi m'ont dit que j'étais plus présent
si j'ai plus disponible parce que quand
ils voulaient et et agir avec moi mais
j'étais jamais caché derrière un écran
ou un livre ou en train d'écouter
quelque chose alors je peux dire profite
de ces quelques mois là j'ai eu connu
plus d'intimité dans mes relations
j'ai fait plusieurs rencontres j'ai eu
beaucoup plus de conversations j'ai fait
plus l'amour avec ma blonde j'ai fait
plus de jeu avec ma fille est en même
temps j'ai aussi passé plus de temps
tout seul à rien faire au niveau du
travail mais j'ai été plus efficace
j'étais plus productif en partie parce
que le temps que je passais pas
consommer un joli j'en utiliser une
partie de ce temps là pour créer pour
être vraiment concentrés dans ce que je
faisais une certaine façon j'avais accès
à plus d'équité
j'avais plus des espaces gérés moins
l'impression de d'aller rapidement
j'avais l'impression d'aller plus
lentement d'avoir plus de temps il ya un
besoin vital si je trouve qui similaire
à celui qu'on peut éprouver quand on a
envie d'aller au bord de la mer
de quitter la ville pour quelques jours
d'aller à la campagne en montagne dans
la forêt on a envie de reprendre contact
avec la nature avec les éléments il ya
quelque chose de vital danse à la même
façon je crois qu'on va reconnaître de
plus en plus qu on a aussi besoin de se
déconnecter des histoires pas seulement
de la technologie mais des histoires
pour reprendre contact avec notre propre
nature
il ya aussi une pauvreté
un jeune comme ça c'est pas quelque
chose que je voudrais poursuivre toute
ma vie donc dans la fin j'avais envie de
recommencer à nourrir là je suis fier de
ce dont je ne nourris donc c'est
important que que je recommence à le
faire mais pas n'importe comment et pas
avec n'importe quoi et c'est ce qui
m'amène au choix et confortable numéro 2
qui est de consommer le meilleur
histoire est ici j'aimerais faire le
parallèle avec la nutrition on est tous
conscients aujourd'hui que c'est
important de bien se nourrir
même si on le fait pas et même si on
n'arrive pas à s'entendre sur ce que
c'est que bien se nourrir on sait quand
même que manger tout le temps c'est pas
une bonne idée que manger toujours la
même chose c'est pas une bonne idée non
plus on sait que ce que je mange
maintenant vont avoir un impact direct
sur mes émotions mes pensées mon énergie
dans les heures qui suivent
et on sait que ça va ce n'est pas direct
sur ma santé à long terme donc qui je
deviens à long terme et je voudrais vous
demander pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'utilise
pas se savoir qu'on n'applique pas pour
les nourritures médiatique
ici aussi on a besoin de qualité de
variété et de repos qualité 1 est ce que
ce que je me dis que je prends me
nourrit vraiment variété est ce que ce
que je prends me permet de me sortir des
sentiers battus comme lors d'une
conférence tedx et repos mon système a
besoin de se reposer de temps en temps
pour assimiler toute cette information
je crois que la renaissance le renouveau
qu'on souhaite tous et dont on a
tellement besoin
vous revenez au bout du compte des
individus et des groupes qui sont
capables de puiser à toute cette
richesse là et qu'ils vont se permettre
pour prendre le temps de sélectionner de
filtrer ce qu'ils consomment prendre le
temps de digérer pour éventuellement le
transformer c'est eux qui vont créer du
nouveau et c'est notre choix
inconfortable numéro 3 qui est de créer
de nouvelles histoires créer du nouveau
créer de nouvelles histoires c'est
inconfortable
c'est difficile pour bien des raisons
entre autres je crois parce que dans une
société d'abondance comme la nôtre c'est
beaucoup plus facile de sorts de s'en
remettre aux histoires déjà formaté déjà
offerte et bien empaqueté plutôt que de
s'aventurer à bricoler quelque chose par
soi même surtout si on se sent un peu
insatisfait mince en ce sens un peu non
pas insatisfait
on se sent un peu insuffisant celles
ayant un paradoxe dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui les bornes les barrières
tombent les uns après les autres
tout semble possible pour qu'ils aient
suffisamment de d'initiative l'audace de
désir les technologies sont plus
puissants plus abordables que jamais on
devrait se sentir puissant dans un monde
comme ça où on peut potentiellement tout
faire mais quand je regarde autour de
moi et je m'inclus dans ça je vois pas
beaucoup de gens qui se sentent super
héros super puissants super créateurs
non mon téléphone par exemple
je suis potentiellement super puissant
avec ça les plus de puissance ici que ce
qui a permis d'envoyer les hommes sur la
lune mais est ce que j'utilise
pleinement cette puissance
non mais non au contraire m'ont
téléphoné il rappelle le quotidien
du fait que j'utilise en fait tout un
film portion de son potentiel
et puis qu'en plus j'ai même pas eu peur
de répondre à tous les messages qui à
lire toutes les choses qui arrivent sur
mon appareil mon téléphone est vraiment
intelligent et puissant et moi je suis
bien ordinaire en paradoxes mossad ou
l'abondance peut renforcer l'impression
qu'on n'est pas assez
et si je reviens mon expérience des 100
jours je dirais que c'est c'est le
cadeau le plus précieux de cette
expérience le pour moi la pauvreté du
jeu n'ont remis en contact avec ma
propre plénitude
pendant les 100 jours quand je me
j'avais un problème où je me posais une
question et je pouvais pas aller
chercher la réponse à l'extérieur il
fallait que je la puise en moi ou bien
que je m'adresse directement quelqu'un
et le fait de devoir me limiter comme ça
sur une base quotidienne
ça me forçait à réaliser quotidiennement
que je suis assez finalement je suis
même riche
j'ai déjà tellement appris tellement
reçu tellement magazine et l'histoire
d'information de savoir de sagesse même
et vous aussi
quand on se sent riche qu'on sent quand
on se sent plein mais notre capacité à
créer quelque chose de vraiment nouveau
et beaucoup plus grand que quand on se
croit insuffisant petit exemple avant
que je conclus l'hiver dernier j'avais
envie d'écrire un livre entre autres sur
cette expérience sources dont je vous
parle ce soir
mais pour moi écrire un premier jet d'un
livre c'est quelque chose de long dans
le passé douloureux un an deux ans de
dur travail et geslin grenon envie de
changer ça alors je me suis proposé
d'aborder les choses de façon
complètement différent de travailler
avec beaucoup d'intensité dans un très
court laps de temps
et bien vous savez quoi c'était c'était
possible finalement
je les fais à raison de dix mille mots
par jour pendant 7 jours
j'ai produit 350 pages du premier jet
d'un manuscrit réviser ce manuscrit là
c'est une autre paire de manches
mais ce qui est important ici c'est
simplement le fait que en faisant ça
j'ai changé pour toujours l'histoire que
je me raconte à propos de ce que je
crois qu'il est possible
je me suis créé une nouvelle histoire
alors on a parlé de couper des histoires
de consommer de meilleures histoires et
de créer de nouvelles histoires
maintenant qu'est ce que vous allez
faire avec ça est ce que vous allez vous
raconter l'histoire et la croire que
c'est pas pour vous parce que pour vous
tout va trop vite que vous pouvez pas
vous le permettre que ce serait trop
compliqué trop difficile trois nuits en
oubien ce que vous allez à partie avec
la possibilité que peut-être vous
pourriez essayer quelque chose de
nouveau
qu'est ce qui se passait par exemple si
beaucoup pied toutes les histoires
pendant une journée ou une fin de
semaine par mois ou bien encore une
semaine par saison comme ce que j'essaie
de faire en ce moment
si vous faisais ça en famille ou en
couple ou tout seul
qu'est ce que ça vous permettra de
découvrir ou de redécouvrir sur vous
même si au lieu de simplement ingérée et
baigné dans une mer d'information vous
prenez un moment où vous retirer et
assimilé ce que vous avez déjà reçu
qu'est ce que ça vous permettrait de
créer et de nous offrir
je vous laisse avec sa merci